okay uh our next speaker is andre
stefek from the university of nevada in
las vegas
uh andreas is going to be talking to us
about
evidence-based computer science
education
all right thank you very much um and
uh before i start let me just say thanks
for the invitation i
i was really excited to uh to come to
this just because
accessibility and uh talking about
evidence which we're asking to talk
about is sort of near and dear to my to
my heart for sure
um so yeah so my name is
uh andreas steffek almost everyone calls
me steffik
i'm gonna be talking about
evidence-based computer science
education today
uh to sort of give a sense of my own
bias i guess or my own sort of
background
i'm a computer scientist by trade so
unlike steve i'm on the opposite side i
don't know almost anything about
hardware
but i do know stuff about software so
it's sort of the opposite it's
interesting
um and i invent programming language
tools
and a lot of the the infrastructure that
kind of goes around them
but what i study is accessibility sort
of on top and then
how how things are how these
technologies are impacted by people and
the evidence that we use
to sort of understand that um
one of the technologies that i invented
along with my wife number of years ago
is called the quorum programming
language which is used pretty heavily
around especially the united states
uh and if you can't see the picture
because you have a visual disability
there's a wonderful picture of my
two-year-old daughter who's sticking out
her tongue
it is quite adorable okay so
first of all let me just sort of mention
what i mean by evidence
and when i say evidence-based computer
science education
what i'm really talking about is one
piece of it because
computer science and education means a
lot of things right uh computer science
education lives in a context
and so does accessibility you know
there's lots of
things that can impact people when we're
talking about students in the classroom
or uh students right as the how do they
get as
they get out of high school or college
or or great school or whatever they're
doing
and what i'm going to be talking about
today is really one piece of that and
that is the
the programming languages and the tools
that people use
um as part of that now that's just one
part of computer science education it's
not the whole
but as i'll kind of explain it is
actually pretty important to think about
it's just not the only piece so there's
also curriculum scaffolding good
teaching and all sorts of other factors
that
impact computer science education as
well
so let's kind of take a step back in
time and think about sort of where we've
come
from uh in terms of programming so
on the screen right now are sort of two
ideas one is a little console
and another is a text editor these might
seem like they're
uh not sophisticated but but in fact
actually these are very complex
and very sophisticated environments it's
just that
nowadays we've mostly moved on and so we
have
um a lot of computer programming
environment
exists both for professionals and
otherwise so on the screen right now is
a picture of a technology called quorum
studio which is actually a programming
environment
that is uh often used by students in
high school but it's also
very accessible even to people that
can't see so there's
game editors built in that somehow we've
made all the graphics blind accessible
and
stuff like that and on the on the slides
uh there's a video we we have on there
that you can see if you if you'd like to
later that shows how that works
now besides that too computer scientists
sometimes forget
that computer scientists aren't always
the target audience right so
on the screen now is an environment
called rstudio which is a technology
designed specifically for people that do
data science
and data science is fascinating on this
image you can actually observe that
there's really it's really just a
console it's actually pretty old school
what rstudio
is you kind of type code in this console
and it gives you some information
uh in real time and but it also includes
different kinds of features that maybe
computer scientists wouldn't wouldn't
thought about as much like
including the data sets in them and that
understanding the history of those data
sets and stuff like that which is
all kind of built in and
data scientists aren't the only one
either so on the screen now is a picture
of what's called unity 3d
and unity 3d is a fascinating
environment for computer gaming sort of
long gone are the days where you might
just fire up
a graphics engine and write your code in
you know linear algebra
that's that you could do that but it
would be very difficult and
um on in an environment like unity
there's all sorts of properties on the
window you can visually drag and drop
things there's a lot of accessibility
challenges here although they're all
solvable making 3d graphics even blind
accessible is absolutely possible
something i've been working on for quite
a while but the point is
an environment unity caters to a
different target audience
that is still very much so programming
related
and then finally in the united states at
least and i know it's true
in the well and some other countries
uh students are increasingly doing
computer programming at
very young ages so for example uh in
nevada
there's a law that was that i helped
pass called sb200
which basically makes it so that
children between ages
5 and 18 are required by law to learn
computer programming just like you would
learn
math or english or something else and
there are lots of environments for these
young kids with
lots of challenges uh many of which are
accessibility
on the screen right now is a picture of
snap which is actually not accessible
but
um it's an example of a block language
that you can use
at so here's sort of the big picture
point
in the last 40 years or so computer
programming has changed a lot and it
hasn't just
changed in a linear way it's changed
depending upon like what community
you're targeting
what that community needs and that sort
of idea
but the question is what evidence is
actually guiding these change processes
and what does that mean and why do we
care about that well it turns out
if you look at just computer programmers
paying software developers maybe not too
surprising is actually pretty expensive
so there's different ways you can cut up
the data and different sources give
slightly different numbers but
a reasonable estimate i think is around
331.7 billion dollars in wages
per year in the united states alone so
what this means is
when we actually train computer
scientists all the teachers that we
train we have to pay those people
all the students all that sort of stuff
all these people
have to effectively learn in programming
languages
so the moment any of those change we
have to modify
all the curriculum we have to retrain
all the teachers we have to retrain all
the developers
and at 331.7 billion a year
for just the developer loan that gets
pretty expensive
pretty dang fast so but the question is
what does it even mean to sort of gather
evidence on these kind of technologies
well
funny thing i imagine many of you might
be familiar with this whole idea of a
quote-unquote pandemic
well it turns out that historically
before we had
sort of the marvels that we have today
you know a vaccine in just a year or so
hopefully um back in the day in the
early 1700s there was a lot of
claims that were made that were largely
done subjectively
so one of the more famous examples is in
the early 1700s
there were these two fellows one of
which cotton mather was arguing for
um effectively to inoculate i won't go
into the details but basically give
people smallpox
and another fellow william douglas was
like whoa that's wicked that's criminal
and if you read the literature neither
of these people were right and neither
of these people had any evidence
whatsoever
for the kind of claims they were making
even though it turned out that cotton
mather was
sort of kind of right given the
situation that he was in although it's
complicated
so you might say okay cool great example
from the 1700s but what about today
well it turns out that even at places
like the department of defense
this happens still relatively recently
so in the 70s there was this wonderful
darpa meeting
and darpa had set up something on
programming languages and estimated
about three and a half billion dollars a
year was going
into the design of these things because
they kept changing different devices had
different languages
and we essentially saw the same kind of
idea
a fellow named david greece argued our
first speaker talked about having
variables which can contain procedure
bodies as objects the question is
whether or not it is a reasonable thing
to have in the language
and others disagreed you can argue maybe
whether or not those positions are right
but in fact
as it there was effectively no evidence
being presented not just there but there
wasn't even any that existed
at the time but i'll get to that in just
a second so
then what does it mean so it turns out
in other fields
a series of innovations started
happening in the early 1800s
on what it meant to be sort of
evidence-based
uh the one of the most famous examples
by the early 1830s
was this thing called the nuremberg salt
test which basically asked the following
questions
did the experimenter manipulate the
experiment basically
did anybody commit fraud did the people
understudy deceive themselves
like are the people that designed this
thing do they just think it's right
right and then if there was a treatment
like i gave them some kind of technology
or whatever it was
was it actually a fair experiment was
was this a fair
comparison the nuremberg assault test in
sort of
historical irony was actually spawned by
the homeopathists which basically
disproved themselves over time which is
interesting
and this this has gone on for a long
time so by the early 1900s there were
these fellows
this fellow named john stokes who
started arguing we needed to standardize
procedures across
research groups by the 1930s or so
and they would talk about selection and
classification treatments across groups
the idea being
we don't just need individual
experiments we actually need
different research groups that may have
competing interests
to see if they can get the same answer
and to collect data in the same ways
and this ultimately led to a very famous
study that i imagine all of you know
even if you don't know it and that is
the famous study by austin bradford hill
and richard dahl
notably which was the first one not the
first but one of the first randomized
controlled trials
i've heard a million claims about this
idea of randomized controlled trials
and so let's talk about it for just a
second number one is this idea of
randomized controlled trials use both
lab data and epidemiological data
they use statistics but they're not
fully quantitative or qualitative they
can do both
they have multivariate models they have
different kinds of standardized
procedures they have effectively
a large series of checks and balances
that are built into them
to prevent fraud and correctness stuff
like that
and all of you probably know this result
because you know that smoking causes
cancer and that's where this comes from
so this particular technique
interestingly
set up such a revolution in
that field that it caused an 11.2
percent
increase in the number of rcts per year
for like half a century so i mean can
you imagine i can't
that like you have an innovation so
important that it caused
exponential growth in the type of
methodological evidence used in across
an entire field nowadays
these kind of studies and uploads
specifically education
and in um medicine are required by law
because they're so commonplace now
interestingly you might be thinking well
okay cool but what on earth does this
have to do with computer science
education well it turns out
computer science education and education
broadly
has been changing in part because of
changes to the law
specifically an act passed by the obama
administration before they left
requiring randomized controlled trials
as part of the what works clearinghouse
and today the one of the top journals on
computer science education
transactions on computing education has
also adopted formalized evidence
standards or they call them reporting
standards
as part of the peer review process in
other words they're trying to promote
the idea that
we need checks and balances in our
evidence
processes notably they use one called
apa jars but there's others like
consort what works clearinghouse that
are used by a wide variety of journals
across many scientific fields for good
reason
good reason okay so
at this point what we've mentioned is we
know that there's been a long history of
kind of designing these tools and
languages
and that we know that a little bit about
evidence and what it means
in the context of other fields so what's
actually been going on in programming
languages
and what do we kind of know about
computer science education there well
what we do know we know a few things
number one is there's thousands
of programming languages thousands of
these things
and they often have their own syntax
their own semantics
they have giant standard libraries often
they often have their own user
communities context abuse and tools
and in terms of accessibility this is
especially challenging because if you
write
accessibility code on a microsoft
platform
that code is 0 compatible with the code
on apple platforms and then that code is
zero percent compatible on the web and
on android devices and on
other devices etc etc that's a huge
problem because
it means you basically have to write
things for accessibility across many
operating systems platforms programming
languages standard libraries
just to make sure that a kid that is
blind or has some other impairment
i'm sorry some other uh disability um
can actually participate in a meaningful
way
so the question is did we do this based
on some kind of evidence and it turns
out the answer is no
there was a famous study now by a fellow
named auntie hanikayanaho
in 2012 and he showed basically that
between 1976
around the time of that darpa meeting in
2012 there was actually only 22
experiments that could be considered
reliable to put this in perspective
other fields have in the range of
hundreds of thousands of
studies for things that matter like when
death is on the
or let's say 300 billion dollars per
year
and it turns out part of the two is even
when computer scientists are gathering
data
there's a study by amico tom letoza and
margaret
showing evidence that they often miss
things like having a control group
testing people other than themselves
when they write an academic paper
and even the idea of collecting data at
all is not always included in
in academic publications that supposedly
go through a rigorous peer review
process
so before 2012 and just in general we
didn't really
have a lot of data about these things
but we know that anytime these language
products change
we have to build entire is at great
expense
in order to manage it so we make a new
block language all the documentation is
brand new we make a new
programming language for some from some
company all the documentation a great
expense
so what do we actually know about these
tools
and what can we do over time to make
changes so we see some condensing
of these products to be more
evidence-based well we do know a few
things now
one is there's this concept of static
typing
it's basically the idea is that if i
have a variable in my code i have to
type say
what it is like this is an integer or a
number or something like that
it's a minor thing by any standard but
it turns out
programming languages have varied this
for quite a long time and nowadays
there are randomized controlled trials
done in multiple countries
under multiple conditions studies with
and without development environments
studies by other groups like at
microsoft on typescript which found
similar answers
studies on variations on it like
generics or other things and the general
consensus
is that this idea of static typing
actually makes programmers faster
and we know it explains about 14 of the
variants between
developers ballpark so that's number one
number two it turns out in the 60s or
70s or these kind of areas we developed
the syntax that was designed in the
original programming language c
and this syntax needs to go away it
needs to be deprecated
for evidence-based choices notably c
used lots of terminology that really
didn't have a foundation of evidence and
how could it have because they couldn't
have known
exactly what studies would show 40 50 or
60 years in the future
and a lot of the decisions that were
made were things like we use the word
for
to represent the concept of repetition
both block languages and text-based
languages use this kind of terminology
and words like that compare to others
like the word repeat which is actually
semantically meaningful
make a difference so on the screen is
one example of a study
where uh the the programming language
several programming languages were
compared to
this idea of a placebo language the idea
being
in my lab we generated computer code
randomly using random symbols
and we compared them to other languages
like java or perl or languages like that
it turns out some programming of
syntactic choices based on c the
effectively so bad for novices that
randomly generated choices do just as
well
in the studies just was kind of shocking
when we first found it
so besides that there's also easy things
that we know about too for example many
programming languages generate error
messages when they have a problem this
is not unique to text-based languages
both text-based block-based languages
have errors in them this is the fact
and it turns out that these errors the
kind of mistakes human
humans make are so predictable that they
can be derived
through a formal equation with an
exponential decay model and
one of my students found this relatively
recently and this is fascinating because
what it means is
if you look at reports like the idiocy
report on compiler error messages
it turns out small changes to the words
generated by these languages don't
require
any documentation changes not really at
least not
to the core language and it turns out we
can predict very accurately what you
problems humans have and we know the
distribution so how heavy people have
these problems
and it turns out it makes a big
difference off the top of my head i want
to say something like
10 to 20 difference in terms of your
productivity for
relatively younger individuals
so what about other areas like we talked
earlier about data science
and it turns out the data science
community has made a whole bunch of
attempts to try to make data science
easier and unfortunately
a lot of these have not been all that
terribly effective so there was a study
on the use of this concept called
tidy verse and r the idea is one making
things more consistent
which i imagine helps although has never
been tested but number two
they made a lot of changes to like small
syntactic variations in the programming
and it turns out these things didn't
really help that much
and when you look at the data what it
seems to indicate
is that we really need to rethink data
science just like completely you know
like maybe we shouldn't name
every statistical test after an old dead
white
mathematician you know instead of
bonferroni we could come up with a
semantically
meaningful set of names and besides that
too
there's lots of specialized programming
environments so for example if you're
programming on a gpu
the company nvidia made libraries to try
to make that easier but it turns out
because they also didn't use evidence as
their design
part of their design process they
basically missed the mark
in terms of like making it easier
largely just because it was never tested
it was just people kind of guessing or
taking their good faith estimate
but evidence on that sort of idea just
kind of
making good faith estimates seems to
indicate that you need a little bit more
a little bit more evidence in order to
get this right so you kind of need
for something as complex as gpu
programming you kind of need to know
have data to back your assumptions as
opposed to just kind of guessing
now this gets even crazier so for
example in
programming today it's often really
common to just use multiple programming
languages one at once
in 97 of open source projects
it turns out they do this and you can
imagine why like you might use
javascript on the front end php on the
back end an sql server to represent the
database
css for formatting and then html to
represent your particular presentation
and this is insane this is absolutely
nuts
that we've just decided that we're just
going to dump tons of programming
languages in at once
assume that they all do a good job and
then call it a day and so we've been
evaluating this empirically to try to
find out if this makes sense and of
course it doesn't
but the thing is oftentimes what you
find is relatively surprising like it
turns out
in one of the studies that was published
recently if you adjust
the the materials in terms of this
polyglot approach
you can make small little changes to it
and it actually really significantly
improves the situation for
uh novices without hurting professionals
in any
way shape or form which is pretty
interesting but you can't really
understand this kind of work without
like a good grasp of how
randomized controlled trials work and
the statistical methodology and stuff
like that
now you might think too well why don't
we just switch to blocks
that'll fix it all it's a magic wand
right well it turns out
the studies on this show that it does
help but it turns out if you also that
if you look at the data
they have this score called a cohen's d
and it's about 0.4 what that really
means is
that it helps just not very much even
for beginners
so it is in addition with block-based
programming languages
there's also quite a few accessibility
challenges that need to be hammered out
and these are really important because
uh at k-12 it's actually required by law
that students can use anything in the
classroom so in nevada
you can't actually use technologies that
aren't accessible because it's illegal
right so you have to actually manage
that kind of stuff and it makes sense
these kids have
civil rights somebody else does
okay so that's a lot so the broad
purpose is that
when we're designing the technologies
that form the core base
all our curriculum all our designs we
really need to base these decisions on
evidence and i
identified a few based on the literature
that include
deprecate see saw syntax improve error
message design which we know how to do
use static typing in all these languages
uh i didn't put in the slides but
there's this concept called lambdas and
the jury's kind of out on them
polyglot seems to be making things worse
we need to rethink data science almost
completely from the ground up
when we make api abstractions for
libraries we need to use
evidence for them you shouldn't just
guess because it's really easy to
wrong we should use blocks in our
programming language
languages but we need to make them
accessible and then
for accessibility in general across the
board we need to make everything
everywhere accessible as part of these
programming languages in a more
consistent way
make it a lot easier and on the
quorum programming languages quorum
programming language this is kind of the
heart of what we do
we make adjustments to the technologies
based on the data that's coming out in
the literature and that
that we gather ourselves okay
so that's a lot of words but if you're
interested in any of that stuff there's
a
um the quorum programming languages at
quorum language.com
i included on here a video of our new
tool called
quorum studio which is actually uh
solves what's called the accessible
graphics problem basically you can do
any kind of graphical content you can
even use it blind
there's a video on how to do that um i'm
also
part of the access cs4all group along
with richard ladner there's a url up on
the screen on that and then
you can hit me up on twitter at andreas
that is all so thanks for your time i
really appreciate it
thank you uh steph is it okay to call
you that now
yes sir stefan is what everybody calls
me all right
um we do have a couple of comments in
the chat window uh
the first one uh asks people often have
very
individual needs based on their
particular combination of disabilities
how can one hope to get a large enough
sample of a people with a particular
impairment to conduct
a proper rct randomly
that's a wonderful question and it turns
out that when you when you're talking
about individuals with disabilities you
often can't
and that's just the truth so like let me
look at if we go back to this particular
slide here
when we do some of these studies we do
comparisons across
averages of people that don't
necessarily have particular impairments
so in this particular design there's
three graphs on the screen
uh two three different experimental
groups and then in each
there's this thing that says hybrid
streaming and object and then there's
groups of freshman sophomore juniors
seniors and professionals we can do that
because there's a number
the average across these people happens
to be pretty similar
but this gets really tricky with
disabilities for example
what is the average blind person right
well that
it almost doesn't even make sense
because if you have
a particular user that's blind and one
of them can't see the screen at all and
uses a screen reader
well that person is very different than
someone that has like color impairments
or other issues like that
so our cts are not magic they're not a
silver bullet they're really useful for
some things but when you want to do work
with people with disabilities
sometimes equals one studies are really
appropriate where you work with one
individual or one person
or sometimes kinds of field analysis can
be really useful
in other words at the end of the day you
want to use evidence and rcts are really
important and useful
for language design but they're not the
only technique you need
and so that's really important
especially for people with disabilities
great all right we've got one more
question and i think just enough time
for you to answer it
uh in your studies have you found that
programmers who started out in
text-based programming and were later
introduced to block based
came to prefer the block based format
i'm asking since i personally started
out with text based
and i can't see myself comfortably
switching to block based
yeah so that's a good question so the at
the leading expert on this issue is
actually named david weintraub
he's a he's a he's done quite a few
studies on this issue
related to swapping back and forth and
also this issue
of like whether it's effective and those
sort of concepts
i couldn't tell you whether or not
you you know this sort of longitudinal
thing because i don't think that's ever
been evaluated in the literature
but david did do a really wonderful
slide but he did this wonderful study on
watching
students kind of flip back and forth
between
text-based and block-based programming
languages is from a
few years ago at the 60 conference and
basically what he found is that
different people
vary a lot in terms of their preferences
but the results are going to say at
least in my head my interpretation of it
is that adding blocks to a programming
language needs to be optional
because people will have different
preferences and that's probably okay and
it seems to fit with the evidence
in other words i don't think you should
force people to use block based
modalities
but having it as an option has been
shown to increase
uh learnability by a cohen's d of 0.4
which is not very much
in other words it's not a huge effect
and if it's optional then it seems like
it does still
work according to wendra as far as i can
tell
great absolutely thanks very much um
someone else posted uh another url for
additional context if anyone would like
to uh check that out oh
and then i think there's one more
question uh
i here i'll read the last question uh
but you'll have to answer it really
quickly because i don't want to eat into
the next speaker's time
how do you anticipate managing the need
to maintain high standards for
innovations in education accessibility
with the desire to innovate
and iterate quickly with the rate of
growth of software changes
how can developers be encouraged to take
the time to make tools accessible
where is the incentive for the time
commitment and you've got 90 seconds to
answer
yeah no problem so what this is actually
this is actually a great question
and it's really a challenge including
for my group so for example
we can't run a randomized controlled
trial and everything it's not possible
there's hundreds of thousands of
studies that you could run they're not
all equally they're not all equally
matter and
there's no incentive to do that anyway
for companies or individuals
but the question is which
things would cause the most pain for
industry and
education by having them change for
example if all of a sudden all the
looping structures change
that impacts every curriculum everywhere
for computer science education so what
you want to do
is you want the studies that are done to
be thinking about this
impact this broader impacts argument of
where it impacts across the board in
other words
when we're designing stuff in a language
like quorum
we do lots of studies that can impact
the whole infrastructure to
try to prove ourselves wrong but when
we're designing like a library or trying
to be innovative or add it to a certain
or something like that we don't run
studies on every detail because we know
we're targeting a smaller group of
people
in other words what i think it should be
is the more people it impact
the more evidence that you should have
and i think that that kind of
jives with what you observe in other
fields like medicine and education and
stuff like that
that's why the fda has a tiered model
basically
all right super thank you very much and
thanks for the really interesting talk
very much appreciate it thank you very
much i appreciate it